[Music]
see takes place about 600 years after a
viral apocalypse those who survived for
left blind and the world has gone back
to a tribal culture it's so very
different it's just something that has
never been done before we've been
working with to build this world what it
looked like what would feel like
the world has been rebuilding itself
both in the natural environment that we
see here also the kind of people and how
they live together there is a beauty
about it
mankind with nothing to distract other
than to keep life going the idea is that
the human beings who did all the damage
that the earth in the first place can't
see it then vision comes back the
ability to see characters who were blind
or visually impaired haven't often had
an opportunity to portray aspects
outside of showing off their disability
I trained actors how we move through the
world and help them understand how
people will utilize their senses in a
different way
and will come for us prepared for a long
journey extra practice cool stuff
that we've never seen before
[Music]
star home we are won by this one
[Music]
the moment has come
centuries from now almost all humans
have lost the ability to see some say
sight was taken from them by God to heal
the earth for the few who remain vision
is only a myth but after so many years
the power of sight has returned what is
it sometimes different children they
have the ability to see
[Music]
my children they have the power that we
would call magical or evil must protect
them
for centuries we feared this day would
come
the evil of light once almost destroyed
the world
and it has returned find the children
who can't see
and bring some to me no flowers if we
kill the babies they might leave us
alone
no I stand with bah-bah-bah
[Music]
we stood in her care
they will print knowledge that will
begin a new world
our family we are one we fight as one
[Music]
you see it has come
it's astonishing how the smallest moment
can change an entire world
you